foreign
Club is breaking boundaries and
shattering stereotypes by having kids
get out of their comfort zones here's
their story
okay so when left arrow move left can
anybody code absolutely it's um it's
more creative than you would think if
you can give someone directions on how
to get to your house or how to make a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich you can
tell a computer what to do it's a club
at Sierra Vista High School called girls
who code and members are on a mission
get rid of any preconceived ideas they
might have about what coders look like
or how hard computer science is the goal
today is to really expand computer
science and try and break boundaries
those boundaries include stereotypes the
gender gap in technology and
socioeconomic status it's enough to lift
a family up and out of poverty if they
get a computer science job you have to
get um score point and attach it the
girls who code do something called Game
Changers they teach coding to non-coders
like the football or wrestling teams
the girls want to show these athletes
that coding moment where they just get
it my little brother could
do the
understand something they can't help it
their hands go up and they get really
excited best part is when you make it
work and it was the game works good
feeling yeah after coding the athletes
return the favor we'll work no works and
teach the girls who code about their
sport or program
protecting my legs from what
oh
this is wrestling I think it's actually
pretty nice because
we as athletes to probably do something
for them we can show them something
athletic they can show us something that
they know I think it's very useful for
us too this is actually an area of
Education in Nevada where our kids are
thriving Nevada is leading the the
Forefront I guess of computer science
and education why is that we wrote
standards for our state before anybody
else did about what things that kids
should learn for some it is becoming a
career calling we're trying to get kids
not only ready for the jobs that are
when they get done with school but the
jobs that are currently available today
I would love to go into something in
robotics where I'm able to program
computers and robots to do what I would
like
now if you missed any part of this story
about the girls who code just head over
to 8newsnow.com you'll find a story and
video there